"THE FIVE" ."
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN JUST
RELEASED A CAMPAIGN AD DISGUISED
AS A DNA TEST OR MAYBE IT WAS A
DNA TEST DISGUISED AS A CAMPAIGN
AD.
SHE LADLES HER DNA RESULTS WITH
SOME RELATIVES IN MUSIC AND
INCLUDES ME.
I AM TOUCHED.
THAT HAPPENS EVERY TIME I TAKE
THE SUBWAY.
>> I HEAR SOME OF YOU ARE
REPUBLICANS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HIM CALLING
HER POCAHONTAS?
>> I THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> I THINK IT'S SILLY.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES WARREN
TRANSLATE INTO CHEROKEE AS?
>> SEGMENTS OF NATIVE AMERICAN
AND ANCESTRY.
>> THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO CALL
MY MOM A LIAR.
WHAT DO THE FACTS SAY?
>> THE FACTS SUGGEST YOU
ABSOLUTELY HAVE NATIVE AMERICAN
ANCESTRY IN YOUR PEDIGREE.
>> Greg: HER NATIVE AMERICAN
ANCESTRY MAY DATE BACK SIX TO
TEN GENERATIONS.
POTENTIALLY 11,000 -- USING SUCH
STANDARDS, I AM ASIAN WHICH
IS WHY I CAN'T GET INTO HARVARD.
NO WONDER SHE HAD TO RELY ON
SENTIMENT AND VICTIMHOOD.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT HISTORY BUT HER
STORY AND FIXING IT BECAUSE IT'S
A MESS.
DID SHE OR DID NOT LIST YOURSELF
AS A MINORITY IN LAW SCHOOL
DIRECTORIES WHEN IT SUITED HER
AND THEN REMOVED IT WHEN HE
DIDN'T?
IT'S NOT ABOUT HER BACKGROUND.
IT'S ABOUT CHEATING.
SHE IS A WHITE WOMAN OF VAST
EUROPEAN ANCESTRY WHO WENT TO
THE BUFFET OF IDENTITY POLITICS
AND TOOK SECONDS AND THIRDS.
WARREN IS NATIVE AMERICAN
BECAUSE SHE SAID SO.
SHE WINS THE 2018 RACHEL DALZIEL
AWARD.
SO IF WE ALL DO THE SAME TEST IS
HERS AND FIND SIMILAR
PERCENTAGES, AREN'T WE ALSO
ELIGIBLE TO CLAIM THE
EXPERIENCES OF AN OPPRESSED
GROUP AND THEIR PAST GRIEVANCES?
HER RESULTS BECOME THE STANDARD
FOR ANYONE CHOOSING A PATH THAT
OFFERS AN EDGE, WHO CAN SKIP
AHEAD IN ADMISSIONS WERE JOBS IN
PLACES WHERE DIVERSITY TRUMPS
EXPERIENCE AND SO DNA TEST
BECOME THE NEW AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
AT WHOSE EXPENSE?
MAYBE NO ONE BECAUSE IF WE ARE
ALL A LITTLE OPPRESSED, WE ARE
ALL GOOD.
GOODBYE, IDENTITY POLITICS.
IF EVERYONE IS A MINORITY, THEN
NOBODY IS.
THERE'S A SILVER LINING.
I THINK SHE DID THE NATION A
SERVICE.
WE ARE ALL NATIVE AMERICAN.
INTERESTING FACT FROM MICHAEL
AARON, WHAT'S HIS NAME?
THE G.O.P. SPOKESMAN.
"NEW YORK TIMES" SOURCING.
THE AVERAGE EUROPEAN-AMERICAN'S
.18.
THE AVERAGE EUROPEAN-AMERICAN IS
ACTUALLY MORE NATIVE AMERICAN
THAN SHE IS.
DID THIS BACKFIRE?
>> Dana: A LITTLE BIT.
A LOT OF THE MEDIA WERE TREATING
THIS AS HER RESPONSE TO TRUMPET
SHE'S GOING TO HAVE TO GET
THROUGH DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY AND I
IMAGINE IF IT GOT DOWN TO THE
TOP TEN THAT HER OPPONENTS WERE
GOING TO USE THIS --
DONALD TRUMP WASN'T GOING TO
HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
I THINK SHE'S OVERREACTING A
LITTLE BIT.
DO YOUR POINT, SHE'S NEVER HAD
TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION.
WHY DID SHE NOT LISTED WHEN SHE
WAS APPLYING TO LOWER TIER
SCHOOLS?
ONLY LISTED IT WHEN SHE APPLIED
TO THE HIGHER TIER SCHOOLS AND
THEN DID NOT LIST IT AFTER SHE
HAD TENURE.
THAT'S THE PART -- EVEN IF YOU
ARE NATIVE AMERICAN, WHY DID YOU
LISTED WHEN YOU ONLY THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO HELP YOU GET AN
EDGE?
>> Greg: GOOD POINTS.
JUAN, IS THIS ABOUT TRUMP OR THE
PEOPLE SHE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
FACE BEFORE TRUMP?
>> Juan: IT WAS ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE TRUMP
ATTACK, CALLING HER POCAHONTAS
AND RIDICULING HER IN THAT WAY
SO I THINK SHE WANTED TO
RESPOND.
NOW I THINK IT'S LIKE JIU-JITSU.
SHE THINKS SHE'S PUT THE
PRESSURE ON TRUMP.
THE KEY THING HERE FOR ME IS
THAT WHEN THE PAPERS ASK THE
FOLKS AT HARVARD, DID YOU INFECT
CONSIDER THIS WHEN YOU HIRED
HER, THEY SAID NO.
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA, I
THINK THEY SAID AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA THEY
FILLED OUT A FORM EXPLAINING WHY
THEY HIRED A WHITE WOMAN OVER
MINORITY PEOPLE.
THE WHOLE BASIS, THE FOUNDATION
OF THE TRUMP ATTACK WAS "YOU USE
THIS TO GET AHEAD FALSELY."
IT TURNS OUT THAT'S NOT TRUE, IN
ADDITION TO WHICH SHE HAS SOME
NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTRY.
>> Greg: >> Katie: I WOUD
>> Greg: >> Katie: I WOUS
>> Greg: >> Katie: I WOUG
>> Greg: >> Katie: I WOUE
>> Greg: >> Katie: I WOU.
IN 1997, FORDHAM UNIVERSITY, THE
LOWER VIEW DESCRIBES WARREN AS
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL FIRST WOMAN
OF COLOR.
THEY HAD THAT CEMENTED IN THEIR
LEGACY.
THE FUNNY THING ABOUT THIS TODAY
LOOKING AT THIS, THE WAY THE
MEDIA REACTED CALMLY FOR REALLY
LOOKING AT THE STUDYING GOING
THROUGH THE NUMBERS, IT WAS
WARREN VERIFIES THAT SHE'S
NATIVE AMERICAN.
"THE BOSTON GLOBE" GOES THROUGH
A SERIES OF CORRECTIONS BECAUSE
FIRST THEY WERE SAYING IT WAS
1:30 SECOND.
THEN THEY GO ALL THE WAY TO
CORRECTING IT DUE TO A MATH
ERROR AND IT TURNS OUT TO BE ONE
IN 1,024.
GOING DOWN THE LINE OF THE
IMPOSSIBILITIES OF THE POINT YOU
BROUGHT UP IN THE SENSE THAT
SHE'S LESS NATIVE AMERICAN THAN
THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS.
>> Juan: DO YOU THINK SHE IS
OWED A MILLION BUCKS BY TRUMP?
>> Greg: I WOULD SAY I THINK
IT WOULD BE GOOD FOR
DONALD TRUMP TO DONATE THAT
MONEY, WRITE IT OFF.
AND THEN THANK HER FOR -- HE
POINTS OUT EVERYONE IN AMERICA
IS NATIVE AMERICAN.
SHE HAS DONE A SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THE WORK FOR
ME.
>> Pete: I CAN SEE THE
CAMPAIGN T-SHIRTS.
"I AM BLACK."
"I AM HISPANIC."
"I AM JEWISH."
WHATEVER.
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO BE.
TO YOUR POINT.
IT'S EXPLOITING MINORITY STATUS.
SHE DID IT TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WITH THE PRESIDENT DID WAS
DEVASTATINGLY LAY OUT HOW SHE
USED IT FOR OWN ADVANTAGE
CONTINUES TO USE IT FOR OWN
ADVANTAGE.
AND NOW SHE THINKS SHE'S GETTING
AHEAD OF IT.
NO, SHE'S CREATING MORE OF A
PROBLEM FOR HERSELF.
SHE CAN'T GET PAST IT.
THIS WILL MAKE IT WORSE.
>> Dana: TERRIBLE POLITICAL
TIMING.
22 DAYS UNTIL THE MIDTERM
ELECTION.
DEMOCRATS LOSING GROUND WITH
MANY REPUBLICANS BUT THEY HAVE
AN EDGE, ESPECIALLY IN THE
HOUSE, NOT THE SENATE.
THEY HAVE ALL THIS MONEY.
THEY COULD'VE USED ALL DAY
TODAY, ALL THIS WEEK THEY
COULD'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT.
SHE HAD TO RELEASE IT TODAY?
WHY NOT DO IT THE DAY AFTER
ELECTION?
MOST OF THE DEMOCRATS -- OBAMA'S
COMMUNICATIONS PERSON WAS
PULLING HIS HAIR OUT SAYING WHY
WOULD YOU DO THIS TODAY?
DOESN'T HELP ANY OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS STORY ABOUT THE DNA TEST
CAME THE DAY AFTER A
"WASHINGTON POST" STORY ABOUT
HOW GREAT SHE'S BEEN, ALL OF
THESE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES.
ONCE THEY WIN THEIR PRIMARIES,
SHE'S THERE WITH A PHONE CALL OF
SUPPORT AND MONEY.
SHE'S DOING A LOT TO TRY TO
BUILD UP A LOT OF SUPPORT WITHIN
THE PARTY AND THEN SHE DOES
THIS.
>> Katie: SHE'S HAVING SERIOUS
PROBLEMS ON THE LEFT.
IF SHE THINKS THIS IS GOING TO
HELP HER BY CLAIMING THE
UNSUBSTANTIATED EVIDENCE THAT
SHE HAS MINORITY STATUS, ON THE
LEFT, IT'S A PROBLEM WITH THE
INTRODUCTION---
INTERSECTIONALITY.
THERE'S THIS EVIDENCE IN LOWER
VIEWS THAT YOU ARE CHOSEN ON THE
FACT THAT YOUR NAME WAS LISTED
AS A MINORITY PROFESSOR BEFORE
YOU GOT TO HARVARD LAW.
SHE HAS PROBLEMS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE.
IN THE PRIMARY FOR 2020 AND IN A
GENERAL ELECTION.
>> Juan: FROM THE DEMOCRATS'
PERSPECTIVE, I DON'T THINK YOU
ARE RIGHT.
>> Dana: I WAS QUOTING JIM
MESSINA.
>> Juan: HE WAS SAYING TIMING
MIGHT BE AN ISSUE BUT NOT ALL OF
THIS OF PILING ON.
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING, TO MY
MIND, WHAT COMES OUT IS HERE'S
ANOTHER TRUMP FALLACY.
POCAHONTAS, HE LIKES TO RIDICULE
PEOPLE.
>> Pete: 1% CONSTITUTES AN
ETHNIC BACKGROUND?
>> Juan: HER FAMILY HISTORY
WAS THAT HER GREAT-GRANDMOTHER
GREAT-GRANDMOTHER --
>> Greg: AND SHE LIED ABOUT IT
ANYWAY.
>> Juan: TOLD HER --
>> Pete: I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
TELL A FOLKTALE ABOUT MY MOTHER
AND THEN PRETEND IT'S TRUE.
>> Juan: I'M SAYING THAT WAS
HER FAMILY STORY.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW.
>> Katie: SHE KNOWS NOW.
>> Greg: MY 23 AND ME HAS ME
AT 2% NATIVE AMERICAN WHICH IS
ACTUALLY MORE THAN HER, SO I AM
WELCOMING HER TO MY FAMILY.
TO THE POINT, IT'S A BIGGER
POINT, IS THIS THE NEXT STEP IN
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION?
DNA TESTING?
EVERY SINGLE PERSON, WHEN YOU
ARE APPLYING FOR COLLEGE, YOU
GET --
>> Dana: YOU DON'T JUST GET TO
CHECK THE BOX.
YOU HAVE TO SEND IN YOUR
RESULTS.
I AM 1% ALBANIAN, REMEMBER THAT?
>> Katie: I WAS TOO SCARED.
I WAS ABOUT TO DO THAT TEST THAT
WAS SITTING THERE FOR A YEAR AND
I GOT FREAKED OUT READING THE
TERMS OF SERVICE AND PUT IT BAC
BACK.
>> Juan: WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS OF THE TABLE,
BUT IF YOU ARE APPLYING, YOU
REALLY WANT TO BE WHITE
UPPER-CLASS.
>> Greg: MAYBE NOT HAVE GOTTEN
INTO HARVARD.
>> Juan: HARVARD SAID THAT'S
NOT TRUE.
I AM SAYING UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, HARVARD OR SAME
SAME THING.
FORDHAM UNIVERSITY SAID WE THINK
THIS WOMAN --
BUT IT DIDN'T IMPACT YOUR
ABILITY.
>> Greg: WE ARE PROBABLY GOING
TO SEE HOW HARVARD REALLY THINKS
IN THIS ASIAN DISCRIMINATION
CASE.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE HOW THEY